it's about that time in this overeager
underwhelming presidential race when you
might be asking yourselves who are you
all and why does Hillary Clinton look
different that is Republican candidate
Carly Fiorina the other woman when it
comes to the polls the former
hewlett-packard CEO is creeping kind of
like a certain pontiff and a Kentucky
clerk hmm dureena is a former Senate
candidate whose campaign strategist
thought this attack ad was a good idea
Tom Campbell is he what he tells us or
see what he's become over the years a
wolf in sheep's clothing and in case you
haven't noticed she is a she which is
great because somebody in the GOP clown
cars that got asked for directions now
the map says we passing a phobia 50
years ago but we could have sworn that
we saw signs for it up ahead
throughout her career Fiorina has taken
a lot of heat for being a woman recently
from a constipated cherub who criticized
her looks
- which Fiorina replied I think women
all over this country heard very clearly
what mr. Trump said
but hold the Destiny's Child Farina is
against the one American institution
that is all about empowering women and
I'm not talking about dove no she hates
Planned Parenthood and her magical
realist description of the
organization's fetal tissue donation
made quite the impression watch a fully
formed fetus on the table its heart
beating its legs kicking while someone
says we have to keep it alive to harvest
its brain
yeah that's made up we we now know the
only thing being harvested for its brain
is governor Scott Walker
nope sir nothing near worth saving fun
fact
Furion is maiden name is actually Sneed
which is coincidentally the sound her
face makes after she makes it up like
when she was pressed about that Planned
Parenthood scene which doesn't exist
that scene absolutely does exist me see
but let's focus on her politics she
opposes federally mandated maternity
leave she wants to repeal the Affordable
Care Act and she opposes a federal
minimum wage in a platform called
because we're all married to AT&T
executives she's also not that into
politics herself she skipped voting in
most California elections when she was
living there and didn't vote in two
national primaries even though she and
her husband are big political donors
Purina says she quote really didn't
think my vote mattered because I didn't
have a direct line of sight for my vote
to a result in other words it's just
better to buy candidates darling so what
our fiorina's qualifications she was
once named the most powerful woman by
Fortune magazine but later her name was
floated as one of the worst CEOs of all
time that's because during her six years
at HP she laid off 30,000 people and the
company's stock lost half its value but
she got a 40 million dollar severance
package
now that's an American dream even a
constipated chair PDF behind Farina is
robotic unreliable ineffective not
unlike an HP printer
oh I'm sorry demon sheep I'm sorry I
didn't mean it
I just what are you
or maybe he's been more himself than
ever
yes yes he danced